Jonathan is on the line in Orange County
hi Jonathan welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show the cocky sir
you too sir how can I help okay so I've
been talking with navient over the last
year and I thank you for your video
shoots and suits and sharks so I kept
going back and forth on the private
loans to come to a settlement offer and
they've decided to accept my thirteen
thousand dollar payment awesome
so that would wipe out one hundred and
twenty six thousand Wow now I see I can
do that in about eight months and they
sent sent over the letter in writing so
it's official and the first payment goes
out on the fifth okay
however that means we're gonna basically
convert this bet on a 1099 you see I
found out federal they don't do this but
they do on private so I'm expecting
about a thirty two thousand dollar tax
bill so I wanted to ask if I paused like
that snowball and just lump up cash as
fast as I can to give to Uncle Sam yes
okay
yeah that's coming that's real and yeah
debt debt forgiveness is going to be a
taxable event and the amount of debt
that's forgiven is as if it's income and
if they're going to turn it over you're
going to have that bill you've you need
to get ready what's your household
income I make one hundred forty thousand
a year okay cool so but but still the
good news is even 32 plus thirteen this
turns out to be a deal right now in the
worst case like once that's not my
overall debt I mean we're talking on
like fifty four thousand and consumer
debt good good
well everything I'm just running through
the back of my mind as I kind
I think I might just go ahead and pay
them the 13 faster be done with them and
then build and then build up the 32
straight in a row yeah see I mean you
could probably pay them in what three
months for every dollar I have about
2171 per month all right and so that'd
be six months and then you got to come
up with 32,000 still but you are
scheduled to pay them how much yeah so
you're thirty thousand bucks a month
give or take right right now one other
factor is in my salary contract they
have a end of year bonus for twenty one
thousand so that was the next step to
just throw that at it and yep yeah I
think they're gonna be done we go I
would go ahead and get navient done and
then I would start piling up cash for
the taxes and then once that is done
then I would restart my debt snowball
okay yeah let's knock out the 13 then
let's knock out the 32 and then let's
restart the dead snowball and that's
what I would do and let's take advantage
of this deal get it over with get the
taxes behind you you don't want to
ignore taxes they will come back and hit
you even harder than anything else
penalties and everything else so yeah
that that's exactly what I would do
hey good question